this was supposed to be Liverpool's year
at 25 points clear a Premier League win
and victory parade along these streets
seemed inevitable
[Applause]
and then came covert 19 it put the
season and the dreams of millions on
hold but it can't stop everything baby
Mel is nine days old born into a crisis
she won't remember been so surreal
no one's calm it was about two days
afterwards it was dad come first look
through the window and after meeting
through the window on you think after
we've gone I cried that's right that's
the first time I cried and I thought
that's not how life should be when
you've got a new baby
Vicky is an NHS midwife her family have
been desperate to see the baby but to
protect her colleagues still at work
she's kept grandparents out we are gonna
party when it's all the boundaries
they're gonna have a party awfully you
say you know you're gonna have big
street parties but are people gonna do
that because is it gonna be in the back
of the mind that it's still not
completely gone that in the back of my
mind is it are you gonna get massive
gatherings again Steve's away I don't
think I don't think you will this
outbreak has forced people apart
well being that's not to brake the
wheels on social distancing this weekend
as is expected to get up to 18 degrees
across the northwest in Stockport on the
outskirts of Manchester this is how
Andrew bowel doc is coping a one-off
outing dress like this has become a
daily routine and a daily highlight for
bored neighbors some have even joined in
well God loves all this is all
overlooking this great that's great to
hear
all right people need some light
heartedness and that includes the man
under the mask I was having some low
days I mean I actually suffer from
depression and anxiety so obviously at
the beginning before I started doing
this it was rather difficult but seeing
people come together laughing joking
waving it's somewhat lifting and that
has really helped me as well so we're
all getting a little bit of something
out of it that sense of coming together
as helping people survive this uniting
communities even those deeply divided
after brexit across the Pennine in the
Northeast Sunderland was a city torn
into between those who wanted to stay in
the EU are you Heather hi Catarina and
those like Heather Govan
desperate to leave all of us thinking
well that's it we're gonna go off always
and now we're gonna make plans and how
England's gonna go forward as a country
the whole overhauled the UK and it just
seems like the Coronas just put a
massive halt to all of that at the
moment scary you know all sorts of bills
I've got appeared know for the van
so if dobbsy the money stops coming in
then then the business of probably and
of dying
taxi drivers a thick bob was in the
minority in Sunderland he voted to
remain there was a lot of here and now
we were talking about coronavirus
which actually has actually brought some
unity there a lot of people and brought
humanity but there's people who started
their care for the elderly who care for
their neighbours but for ZAF who's
self-employed that unity has come at a
cost
what upsets you most but another thing
this is stress of having the carry on
working where's it gonna lead I've got a
family think about them in a lockdown
this is one way to party the coziness is
a wedding DJ but his bookings have all
been canceled so a time on his hands and
access to a roof terrace is putting on a
short safe rave people are gonna be
isolated right now and feeling really
alone and so I think that playing that
kind of music where everybody should
have been done together without knowing
people there you feel it all of a sudden
you feel like you're not on the road
[Applause]
we're living a time right now where
everything is about need and necessity
and things being essential so although
15 minutes of music and of alcalá can
seem a little bit frivolous actually
it's really rather moving it just brings
a little bit of joy to a lot of people
at a time when that's exactly what they
need
[Music]
Caterina the Topsy Sky News
[Applause]